welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman today and if you want more from
me for some reason but you can
definitely get it on my youtube channels
at youtube.com slash the ring of fire
and youtube.com slash fahren balanced
so this weekend this past weekend mike
lindell ceo of mypillow
held what he had told us earlier in the
week last week was going to be
the event to end all events
he said after this weekend's event you
will not be able to walk away saying
that all of these claims of voter fraud
are a hoax or that any of this is a lie
you will all be convinced he said
that the voter fraud happened because
that is how serious he is about it and
that is how awesome
the evidence that he has
was gonna
be well it's tuesday
so the event ended on sunday
there was 12 hours on saturday 12 hours
on sunday
and i don't know if you've noticed this
in case you haven't checked
donald trump is not president again
there were not massive reports over the
last 48 hours of amazing evidence of
voter fraud
revealed by the pillow man
in short
mike lindell once again lied to
everybody about everything
and instead according to reports spent
most of his time over the weekend
complaining about the media
whining and crying
about media coverage of him and his
claims
and his multiple now cyber symposiums
he had a couple lawmakers show up
marjorie taylor green showed up and
we'll get more to that in just a few
minutes but uh
yeah
no earth-shattering revelations
no oh my god trump actually won the
election claims from anybody on the left
or the right
he basically paraded a bunch of people
up on stage who said the election was
stolen bye
but nobody gave us any evidence
you're watching this
so i'm going to go ahead and assume that
you're not one of the people that thinks
the 2020 election was stolen
congratulations if that does apply to
you because you live in reality i live
in reality
we know that there was no fraud in the
2020 election to the degree that would
have overturned the election results in
any state
heck at this point there's not even
enough to overthrow it in any county any
city any election that was held in 2020
not enough fraud to overturn any of it
instances here and there absolutely most
of them trump supporters by the way
but no widespread
no irregularities with the voting
machines
no foreign countries hacking in with
their space lasers to change the votes
nothing
and mike lindell as i said has now had
three
multi-day cyber symposiums where before
each and every one of them he swore up
and down i'm going to give it all to you
it's all coming out this weekend here it
comes get ready for it
nothing
not a thing
so mike i gotta ask you bud where is the
evidence
you say you've had it you've literally
now been saying it for over a year
that you're gonna do it and once you do
it it's all over everybody you still
don't even do it
so my question at this point is how can
anyone
even your most die-hard election fraud
believers how can you watch this man
lie to your face for over a year
about presenting you this evidence he
gets up on stage doesn't present you
anything
how can you walk away from that and say
this guy's the real deal he's telling
the truth he's telling it like it is
you're being hoodwinked and honestly i
do still feel sorry for you i know i
probably shouldn't
but he is feeding you lies to sell you
pillows and now coffee
because that's what this is
because on screen
the whole time on lindell tv
or if you were one of the 1500 people
who watched it on youtube or rumble
because that's what they peaked at on
their live stream 1500 they had about
400 people in the audience there
he gave you pillow codes
coupon codes to go use at
mypillow.com.com excuse me or my coffee
yeah that's what you got
because that's what this is
i firmly believe this is all just a
massive con job
now that's not to say that lindell
doesn't believe his own claims i also
believe that he believes it
but i also think that he understands
this is the best possible marketing he
could ever hope for
he still labors under the guise that all
publicity is good publicity no matter
what even bad publicity is good
publicity
he wouldn't be putting coupon codes for
his website
on the screen throughout the whole thing
if he didn't want to use this as a money
making operation folks
you're being had you're being strung
along by a charlatan
that knows he doesn't have any any
evidence to back up any of his claims
but he can continue to promise you the
world and they're gonna continue to eat
it up
but maybe after this one just maybe
maybe there's enough sane people left
out there who had been following in
following him that maybe they look at it
and they say you know what i can't
i've been through three cyber symposiums
now and you've given me nothing i have
to move on with my life
i hope that happens
but i doubt it will
one of our longtime sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you 50 dollars off as
many of you know i am not vegetarian but
i think eating plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now whether you're
vegan or you just want to add an easy
delicious way to have more plants in
your diet splendid spoon is a great way
to go there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates constantly i've tried a lot of
different meal subscription services
splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when i'm on the go and you'll
get fifty dollars off your first week
when you subscribe at splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below